you know so often when you see a final
product of an entrepreneur we tend to
look at them and say man he or she made
it because they're so amazing at this
they're so amazing at that there's so
many thing at this but we look at
ourselves and say I can't make it
because I'm terrible at this several at
that turbo like this but the challenge
is when you look at this person you know
we don't see to come back they have to
make I guarantee you whoever becomes
gets at the top of the mountain on any
spectrum especially in business they
have to overcome a lot of things so
today I want to talk to the people that
maybe have hit rock bottom you've hit a
plateau plateau you lost everything you
file the bankruptcy a bad relationship
Batman you lost everything you had and
you no longer feel like you have what it
takes to come back I won't talk to you
today I'm speaking to you today
I'm gonna talk about eight things you
got to do to make a comeback because I
remember for myself when I had
rock-bottom
I remember today I talked about it this
morning on a conference call
I remember how painful it was I remember
what it was all about I remember a
painful day for me that I just told
myself I'll never do this again it's
very similar to a bad breakup when
somebody breaks your heart which I
believe is one of the most important
things to ever happen to anybody you've
got to have your heart shattered at one
point of your life my opinion because it
teaches you a lot and the sooner it
happens in your life the better it is
sometimes when it happens too late we
don't know how to recover from it but
it's like a relationship you know how
sometimes we're in a relationship and
that person you know hurts you cheats on
your lies you know you know breaks up
leaves you for your bet whatever it is
when that happens a lot of times we come
out of that relationship may say you
know he's a liar he said this he said
that he's the worst person she's the
most terrible person in the world and
thought that thought that I will never
date another person again I will never I
will never do this I want to be by
myself for the rest of my life and we
know it's a lie but we coz were hurt
right business is similar and the
challenge like in a relationship is
you've gone a year two years three years
with this person like oh my gosh I don't
want to date another person and have to
learn there they have to learn my
Earth's and my things that I do that I
need to go through that process I don't
same goes for business this is why very
very very very few people make a
comeback after one failure to failure
three failed
very few people make it because they
know what it takes to come back and have
to take it to that level again they
don't want to do that this is why most
people if they knew I must speak to you
right now before I get into these eight
points if most people knew what it took
to build a multi multi-million dollar
business very few people would actually
start a business
very few people to actually start a
business but let me give you the
complete opposite side as well its if
most people knew what it felt like what
it feels like when you finally build it
and you have the success and you look at
the product and you say my gosh I cannot
believe what I've built I guarantee you
people would be 10 times more urgent
about making it happen but most people
are afraid of the work they've got to
put in most people are you're watching
this right now you're telling me so I
don't know if I want to go what if it
doesn't work what if it doesn't do this
just listen to it and see what you got
to do because at the end of the day to
make a comeback there's a lot of great
feelings when you do make a comeback if
you do but this is why guys you know
credits got to be given to people who do
make a comeback
that's why there are heroes you know
that's why heroes are made because most
people are not willing to do what heroes
and legends want to do most people don't
want to go through the challenge in
times they'd rather live a life of an
average life and just make it a simple
life and whether you agree with this or
now most people are trying to take the
easy route and it doesn't exist so let
me talk about the comebacks okay and I'm
not going to give you a motivational
talk you can do it you can this is not
the motivational comeback this is a very
there'll be an emotional side to but
it's more of your logical side point
number one first I'll find out why you
failed in the first place first thing
you got to do find out why you failed in
the first place why did you fail okay
and just like in a relationship many
times we can say well she did this well
he did this no one cares
the only thing you need to find out is
what you did wrong forget about what
that person did wrong it's irrelevant no
one cares in the world of free
enterprise the world of free enterprise
has this much feelings for your emotions
this much it does not care how you feel
it truly doesn't care how you feel
it doesn't care for the hurts you if you
lost all your money you lost you credit
nothing I've had the worst credit in the
world I've had a 484 credit I've lost
the love of my life
I've lost run
a ship's I've lost my car I've lost
everything I had I've gone through it
and no one cares and I had to regroup
and take out a pen and paper write down
why did I fail in the first place and
here's what you'll find out okay so so
you make the list of things you control
generally I like to make the list of
things I control once I started making
money
I got casual that's a problem I stopped
paying attention to the money and all of
a sudden I realized we didn't have as
much money in the back as I thought we
do so I couldn't make payroll I had to
fire two people then boom I couldn't
make the business work because a person
I fired was very important I went out of
business yeah when I got a big office
and I couldn't afford to rent because
after three months we went by your
savings and then I was late one month
two months three months of rent and we
have to shut down the office and I don't
know if I want to do it again right you
know but it goes back to figuring that
part out because we're so concerned
about our emotions and our feelings and
the world of business yet we're such big
fans of sports that we don't realize
coaches great coaches like Popovich
great coaches like you know a you know
you can go through a list of and Phil
Jackson you can go through the list of
them with Pat Riley and Belichick they
study videos they study video and they
go back and say I study the video and a
show here's what we did wrong this is
why we didn't win the Super Bowl last
year and we don't like to do that as
entrepreneurs we don't even want to
bring this because I don't wanna think
about this now it makes me feel negative
that's what athleanx
you got to do that you got to man up and
woman up and say this is what I did
wrong and play the video I was asking a
question this morning on a conference
call hey Pat how why is it that you're
so you know you know the way people talk
to you're so chill and you saw that but
you still give the feedback you don't
hold back but there's a certain sense of
humbleness why is that so what do you
mean I said you know why do you have
that part said I said maybe because I
failed miserably early on and it hurt
and there's a level of paranoia that I
don't want that to happen again I live
in America people ask why are you so
paranoid about the freedom in America
because I lived in a country that was
free boom it was completely gone the
next we have to escape and run away from
that
country knows Iran so what do you mean
why are you so afraid there is a certain
benefit you get if you fail you make a
better leader later on if you have
failed in love if you have some setback
you it it makes for a tougher stronger
person to follow because people know
where you're coming from so this is
actually a very good thing that you have
to make a comeback because people will
listen to you more that's point number
one point number one is find out why you
felt in the first place go through the
list and what can you do differently
about it number two realize that you're
not as bad as you think you are and
you're not as good as you think you are
you know when you have a lot of success
people think they're better than they
really are you're not when people fail
people think they're worse than they are
and you're not you're generally in the
middle don't let people for you to
thinking you're incredible and don't let
people for you thinking you're horrible
you're in the middle be very you know
stained equilibrium stay stay in the
middle stay right here you know just
like in politics far-left is not good
for writers and good independent midland
middle is generally good because you can
process everything it also is in life it
also is about your skill set abilities
you can go down in the gutter and no one
want to do business with somebody that's
down in the gutter and no one wants to
business but somebody is so cocky that
they think they know it all people are
entertained by that but man it gets very
annoying and it gives virtute way too
many enemies when you behave from the
stand point all the time you're
generally here number three be prepared
for crap to hit the fan again be
prepared for crap day at the fan again
it's going to but be prepared this time
okay and in a world of boxing if you got
knocked out once before
well keep your guard up you keep your
guard down because you thought you'd
never get knocked out you got to keep it
up right together if you got knocked out
here because you realize you know you
got hit you couldn't breathe anymore
maybe your cardio is not good you got to
get back in the car you got to get your
house stronger if you got up here you
thought your chin was real solid because
you can Hank maybe you've never faced a
fighter like this before
so have a little bit of paranoia you
know be a little bit more paranoid
because craps going to hit the fan but
this time because you're overly paranoid
and you're overly prepared it doesn't
happen and if it does it's like you know
dust off and you're good you move on
it's not disaster where you go out of
business
number four don't back off too much let
me tell what I mean by don't back off
too much when you want to make a
comeback well my son was 18 months old
Tico who he's an incredible swimmer now
the kid swims at 22 months 21 months he
was swimming in the pool all by himself
when it was 18 months old you know he
was swimming once and he fell and I was
there and when he was underwater I
started panicking but he fell and I went
in there and I got him and he came out
it was panicking screaming shouting and
his mom my wife took him out and like no
no no let's not put him in the water and
let's not put him in the water let's not
put him in the water and all I thought
about this man if you get him to face
you got to get back you got a K and hit
again he got a hit you know you just got
to get back in the ring again you just
do it's just one of those things a pilot
goes up some happens you crash eject
whatever you gotta get back up
immediately it's all so it's a rule in
Air Force you got to get the guy back up
immediately or else that stays forever
because a longer last the longer the
fear becomes real it's inside of you so
I took Tico out my son Isaac some come
on and we went by the pool he was
absolutely panicking nah I said hold me
and he's with squeezing he squeezed me
so when in the water and we're in the
shallow and I just said hey just it's
okay I'm just hugging me and we're going
back and we're not so I'm not pushing
him off nothing he's just in the water
no after about thirty seconds one minute
no no no no it's okay daddy's right here
it's okay it's okay pop it's okay pop
tap tap tap it's okay pop it's okay pop
tap tap tap okay that's a tickle yeah
daddy do you think he can swim to the
other side no no no okay
why don't you hold me I'll swim okay so
he holds me I swim we we're in the water
little bit water and all of a sudden
let's go
and he swims again and now you can't
stop the kid from swimming he loves
swimming when you have a setback as an
entrepreneur get back in the ring again
man do not do not get off don't don't
don't get off don't get out of the ring
get back right into it it's it's right
in that moment
you know when you're just like in sales
if you got a rejection go back out again
somebody says no go out immediately
don't let that brain you know dwell too
much on a note for 12 hours I don't like
a note to dwell on my mind for 10
seconds just like a basketball players
shoots they leave on a mate shot
basketball they're still you know
superstitious where they don't leave on
a missed shot from practice they live
leave on a made shot right they live on
it leave on it you got to do the same as
an entrepreneur you got to get back out
there or else it'll stay with you and
you'll never be able to make it as an
ultra because there's always that
hesitation in the back of your mind that
you're not going to go out and play in
office now point number five a point
number five is similar to point number
four with the complete opposites a
message of it it's you know don't back
off too much which is point number four
and get back into it again but number
five is you know
don't stop dating and get back in the
field but just don't get married too
quickly I see a lot of relationships
where a you know guy calls me and a
buddy calls me says Pat I found my wife
we're gonna get married
like just no no you don't understand
this is my wife and on their third date
they're already talking about marriage
look I hear the stories of all this oh
you know it's on our second that we got
married for every one of those stories
there's 50 divorces just so you know
that just telling you this um slow so
when you're going back into dating
especially if the break-up is early just
go slowly and you know kind of figure it
out and get into in business you know
when you're getting back into it you got
to get back into the ring quickly but
you don't want to just say yes this is
what I'm doing look for some things go
through the whole thing find out why I
make them a six in the first place which
one was on you and how can you fix that
you're not as bad as you think you're
not as good as you think you'll be
prepared for crap to hit the fan so this
time ask more questions do some research
find out what's going on meet the
executive meekalito find out more about
the who you going into business with
find out do that get back into it
but before you get married do your due
diligence before you marry get back into
the dating scene but don't get married
immediately assess your situation before
you do that next very simple you know
failure doesn't necessarily define you
it's very simple don't let
define you it's more how you respond to
it than an actual event it's really how
you respond to that makes people really
find that eventually who you are what
you've done in your life point number
seven is a you know seek counsel from
the right source pretty simple get the
right source of somebody who hit your
switch who wasn't your situation like
that and they came out of it and point
number eight is very simple for me read
comeback stories I like to watch
comeback movies read comeback stories
there's plenty of them Howard Schultz
and Steve Jobs were both fired and let
go dr. Seuss was turned down 28 27
different publishers until finally
somebody accepted him and he sold 600
million copies of books but at some
point somebody didn't accept him JK
Rowling Harry Potter didn't pick her up
she was on welfare single mother by
herself doing everything and they
rejected I don't know how many thirty
times with her books number one selling
book in the world ever Harry Potter sold
700 million copies around the world
she's the first female billionaire
around the world as an author how did
that happen I mean I can go on and on
and on with these stories it's not just
one of them there are so many of these
stories for us to come cope go through
and as simple as it sounds you have no
idea how much that helps you out when
you get that source of inspiration when
you hit rock bottom because the reality
part of it is and i'ma tell you this and
you can do whatever you want to do with
this listen there is a reason why we
respect successful entrepreneurs so much
because very few of them make it there's
a reason for that
remember that that's an opportunity for
you very very few entrepreneurs make it
to the highest level very few them do
because it's not easy it's not something
that you know you know it's simple but
it's not because sometimes I no mind the
mind is playing so many tricks and do I
want to get back into it again in it and
I know what it takes to do the work do I
want to do the work but I just want to
settle men I don't know if I want to do
this again I don't want to go through
this again do it but but it's the fruits
of your labor come on you're becoming
when you're in the arena doesn't happen
when you're out there just watching the
arena you can choose to be a fan and a
spectator for the rest of your life but
you know deep down inside you want to be
in the arena in the fight in the war in
the battle with everybody else watching
you in it competing fighting
throwing stuff at you booing you go for
it you can do it you suck you're
terrible
you're the worst I've ever seen but
you're in the arena at least you have to
guts to roll up your sleeves and go out
there and bite - that's the juice that's
the juice of life and when you do make a
comeback you know it meet them when you
make a comeback what do you think your
kids are going to talk about for the
rest of their lives my dad kicked my dad
came back my mom is a fighter my
husband's a fighter my wife's a fighter
there becomes a certain level of respect
and admiration that they'll you're gonna
want to experience it becomes a certain
level of admiration and respect you want
to experience because I've said this so
many times when the time comes where
everybody's there at our funeral and
we're on our deathbed you're gonna
remember these moments where nobody
thought you could do it and you really
didn't feel like doing it you did not
want to do it logic told you don't do it
he motion told you do not want to live
with regrets go make it happen and you
did that's that's when we leave this
planet and we go wherever we go after we
die heaven you want to call it at peace
because we know we fought there's no
value for that you can't buy that at
Walmart it's not for sale they don't
sell that at Nordstrom's they don't sell
it at Macy's not Amazon nowhere online
they sell it through hard work and
dedication without anybody seeing you
and cheering you on sometimes that's
when this happens so if you're somebody
who is at a challenging time in your
life
watch this video again go through these
eight points assess yourself put a plan
of action get back into it don't
hesitate and play office and if you know
somebody maybe it's not you share this
video with somebody you know that's in
the rudder right now they would liked it
in there in the gutter right now they
would like to figure out a way to make
it come back share this content with
them move them challenge them inspire
them tell them to get back into the ring
again because they're this close of
attaining that success that they always
wanted to have
anyways if you got any questions about
it comment on the bottom if you haven't
been to the website go to Patrick MIDI
be calm right here Eliana let's put a
ring
boom Patrick we calm and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel click right
here and subscribe to this channel
thanks for watching take care bye bye